next question today hey David you often
say to callers and guests what would it
take to change your mind well let me ask
you what would it take for you to change
your mind and support the us-mexico
border wall fair question I'm against
the us-mexico border wall but what
evidence if it existed if it could be
presented to me would cause me to change
my position on the wall what you have to
understand is that the reality is that
there isn't actually an immigration
crisis this is a country of three
hundred and thirty three hundred and
forty million people illegal border
crossings are down we have a net outflow
of undocumented immigrants back to
Mexico two-thirds of undocumented
immigrants aren't actually physically
crossing the us-mexico border they're
flying in or coming in via other means
and overstaying visa so a wall wouldn't
do anything about that and then you have
to say okay well there are people
crossing the border border illegally but
is the money that it would take to build
the wall relative to the magnitude of
the problem money that would be better
spent elsewhere would it be a better
investment elsewhere and I would say yes
it is so therefore to change my mind
about the border wall I would need
number one evidence that this actually
is the acute crisis problem that Trump
and his defenders claim it is
I would then need evidence that this is
actually a problem that would be fixed
with the wall and then I would need to
sort of consider whether this is even
worth exploring if we're not going to
start prosecuting companies that are
employing undocumented immigrants
including president Trump's companies
who we now now know have a long history
of employing undocumented immigrants
it's not even worth thinking about any
of these other methods and we can debate
the particular methods that we would
employ unless you're actually going to
punish companies that are hiring
undocumented immigrants because if
companies stopped being willing to hire
undocumented immigrants the demand to
even come over to the United States
illegally would drop drastically and
it's completely unfair to say we need to
spend
taxpayer money on a wall that would even
if 100% effective only reduced by 33%
the number of people coming here
illegally because again two-thirds are
coming here and over staying visas not
by crossing the us-mexico border none of
it even is is relevant unless we're
going to say you can't hire undocumented
immigrants but we're not just gonna say
it we're actually going to enforce it I
don't believe that border security is
particularly weak right now and I
definitely don't want there to be no
security but it is an idiotic way to
spend our money on a wall that if 100
percent effective only deals with 1/3 of
the problem that ignores the reality
that we have a net outflow of people to
Mexico who are undocumented and you know
just to start talking now in fantasy
world
if Trump said hey if we build the wall I
will end private for-profit insurance
and start a single-payer maybe I would
take that trade right but we're now
getting cartoonish like that that's how
that's how strongly the facts point
against spending this money on this wall
and that's what it would take to change
my mind